Florida's recount continues to be
federal Jim Acosta wins a great victory
for Jim Acosta and we checked the
mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show well Jim Acosta wins a big
victory against the Trump administration
which means he is going to bust into
that next press conference like the
kool-aid man right through the wall like
oh yeah so we will discuss Jim Acosta
big win in the courts against the Trump
administration truth is truth is he was
kind of right but I I know I know stop
yourself don't hurl yourself from the
nearest building I'll explain legally in
just a second but first but first let me
talk to you about your imminent demise
so all this week I've been thinking
about death why have I been thinking
about that well because I've been
hacking up along that made me think well
I'm sure glad that I have health
insurance and life insurance more
importantly because life insurance means
that if I should plot if I should die
then my family will be taken care of and
that will certainly be a good thing
right now you can get life insurance
pretty easily at policy genius you know
it's kind of tough to get life insurance
really like you have to go by word of
mouth or you don't know that much about
it but policy genius is the easiest way
to get life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find the best policy for
you
and when you compare quotes you save
money it is indeed that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they've placed over
20 billion dollars in coverage they
don't just make life insurance easy they
also do disability insurance and auto
insurance and home insurance if you care
about it they can cover it so if you've
been avoiding getting life insurance
because it's difficult or confusing give
policy genius to try just go to policy
genius com get your quotes apply in
minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now
policy genius is the easy way to compare
them buy life insurance go check it out
right now
policy genius.com let them know that we
sent you alright so we begin today with
the latest from Florida where I think
the plan is to just recount this
election result forever and then Florida
won't be a problem for us anymore we
won't have any new elections well just
keep recounting this sucker for like the
next 25 years and by that point all the
candidates may have died and it won't
matter because the recount will continue
out in Florida will just be taken off
the board as an actual electoral entity
in the United States the current status
is that Florida has now ordered the
first ever statewide hand recount as the
legal fights continue according to the
Tampa Bay
now let's be straight about this Ron de
santis will be the governor of Florida
Rick Scott will be the senator from
Florida the margins are too big to be
made up in a recount typically the only
time a recount has been reversed in a
statewide race is when the margins are
less than 500 votes in this particular
case Rick Scott is up by several
thousand votes and the same thing is
true for Ron de santis that is not
stopping Democrats however from claiming
that the election has been stolen from
them so you remember just a couple of
days ago we were hearing about President
Trump that that guy undermining
electoral integrity well right now
Democrats know they've lost in Florida
and they still won't acknowledge they've
lost in Florida because they want to
pretend that voter suppression is
happening according to Tampa Bay comm an
unprecedented statewide hand recount is
now underway in the Sunshine State
further extending a high-stakes partisan
battle over every last vote in Florida's
crucial US Senate race following a
five-day machine recount of the more
than eight point three million votes
cast in the November sixth elections
Secretary of State Ken detsen ordered
hand recounts Thursday afternoon in the
race between US Senator Bill Nelson and
Governor Rick Scott and also the race
for agriculture commissioner between
Nicole Nikki freed and Matt Caldwell the
order gives canvassing boards in the
state 67 counties three days to pour
over thousands of ballots that were
rejected by machines because of over
votes where a voter appears to have
chosen more than one candidate in a race
or under votes in which a voter appears
to have skipped erase altogether with
the help of state guidelines the
canvassing boards which are allowed to
enlist the help of volunteers will try
to determine how those voters intend
about okay I have a basic problem I
really do I have a basic problem with
this idea that we're gonna look at the
ballots and then try to determine how
you might have wanted to vote where you
crossed out what you filled in one and
then you cross it out well then you
filled in another right I just have a
general problem with this learn how to
vote if you don't know how to vote go
get another ballot like seriously you
don't get to do this on your scantron on
your SAT right every one of us took the
SAT or the a CT or a lot of us did
anyway or will when you do that you
can't then go back to the SAT board and
say listen guys I want a hand recount of
my SAT score if you don't know how to
fill out a bubble this would be your
problem not the problem of the people of
the United States according to Tampa Bay
comm it is not entirely clear how many
such over votes and under votes exist in
the US Senate race a times-herald
analysis of state and county data showed
the number could be between 35,000 and
118 thousand again if you don't know how
to vote this
is your problem but having a bunch of
people sit there and look into their own
heart to determine how you voted and it
turns out people looking into their
hearts are typically Democrats this is a
problem the determination on how those
ballots were cast could go a long way
towards deciding whether Nelson has
reelected or Scott ascends from governor
to u.s. senator Florida law requires a
machine recount for any race decided by
one half of one percentage points or
less all three races this would be the
the agricultural race the gubernatorial
race and the Senate race all three races
were within the margins when election
supervisors submitted their unofficial
results Saturday to the state I my
suspicious of this process you damned
damn well yes yeah I mean of course I'm
suspicious why am I so suspicious of the
process because Democrats are in fact
attempting to cheat they aren't in fact
attempting to cheat now as you know for
the last week and a half I've been very
skeptical about claims of voter fraud
because the evidence of voter fraud is
not particularly widespread in the
United States the idea people are going
and voting twice illegal immigrants
voting right the numbers are just not
there to support the idea that voter
fraud is widespread in deciding
elections however Democrats are
attempting now to engage in voter fraud
when they extend the election beyond the
election deadline what do I mean listen
to this story this is from Naples news
calm the Naples Daily News quote a day
after Florida's election left top state
race is too close to call a Democratic
Party leader directed staffers and
volunteers to share altered election
forms with voters to fix signature
problems on absentee ballots after the
state's deadline the altered form
surfaced in Broward Santa Rosa citrus
and Okaloosa counties and were reported
to federal prosecutors to review for
possible election fraud as Florida
counties completed it required recount
in three top races but an email obtained
by the USA Today Network Florida shows
that Florida Democrats were organizing a
broader statewide effort beyond those
counties to give voters the altered
forms to fix improper absentee ballots
after the November 5th deadline in other
words they were voting after the vote
was supposed to be in Democratic Party
leaders provided staffers with copies of
a form known as a cure affidavit that
had been modified to include an
inaccurate November 8th deadline so the
idea was they were they were sending
people forums saying you want to cure
your vote you want to make sure that
your vote gets counted well you have now
until November 8th to do that ooh
well when it comes to absentee ballots
the deadline is November 5th otherwise
you are supposed to show up at the polls
yourself you can only
vote absentee by November 5th so now we
are extending election deadlines beyond
the actual election deadline is what
Democrats were trying to do they claim
that all of this was sort of a
provisional thing in case courts decided
you know what maybe we do want to extend
the election deadline but you can't
violate election law this way I mean
it's the equivalent of saying the
election was held November 8th now we're
gonna send out forums saying if you
really wanted to vote November 10th
that's cool you can do that and we're
just gonna send that out there and put
out an affidavit that says that you
voted November 8th when you really vote
in November 10th we're gonna put that
out there and maybe courts will say it's
okay no you don't get to do this one
Palm Beach Democrat activists said in an
interview the idea was to have voters
fixed and submit as many absentee
ballots as possible with the altered
forms in hopes of later including them
in vote totals if a judge ruled such
ballots were allowed because Chief Judge
Mark Walker ruled Thursday voters should
have until Saturday to correct
signatures on ballots a move that could
open the door for these ballots returned
with altered forms to be counted okay
just because there's a judge who's
okaying election fraud does not mean it
is not election fraud an election fraud
does not necessarily mean that you are
casting a vote in fraudulent fashion in
the sense that you are voting for
another person or voting for a dead
person like in Chicago or something if I
vote on November 11th
for a November 8th election I am now
committing election fraud if I if I
punch a ballot and it's my vote I didn't
vote and then I go over to the ballot
box and you sort of slip it in there
even after the election is over
that would be election fraud and this
sort of stuff
is is not too uncommon in Florida I mean
look look at this this is just crazy
talk okay this is from the hill Florida
will not use results from Broward
counties machine recount why remember we
just said a few minutes ago that Broward
County had a mandatory machine recount
under state election law and after that
happened they went to a hand recount
while on Florida use results from
Broward counties machine recount because
the office submitted its results two
minutes two minutes past the 3:00 p.m.
deadline on Thursday we have voted to
the state two minutes late so the state
has chosen not to use our machine
recount results they're going to use our
first unofficial results as our second
unofficial results said Joe D'Allesandro
and electing official well why did that
happen
because there is a difference in the
vote counts what happened when they
machinery counted it turned out that
Rick Scott gained votes in machinery
count does anyone really believe that if
Rick Scott had lost votes in machinery
counts in Broward County that this
somehow would not have been counted that
they would have submitted it two minutes
late does anyone really believe that all
of this really does raise serious
questions about the veracity of election
results and not only that over in
Georgia Democrats continue to claim over
and over without any evidence that
Stacey Abrams should be given now a new
election I am not kidding you they are
now arguing Abrams who's losing by
50,000 votes in that state not a joke
she's losing by 50,000 votes in the
state Stacey Abrams now refuses to
accept the election results according to
the AP Stacey Abrams campaign is
preparing an unprecedented legal
challenge in the unresolved Georgia
governor's race that could leave the
state Supreme Court deciding whether to
force another round of voting so they
want a new election now the Democrats
longshot strategy relies on a statute
that has never been used in such a high
stakes contest it is being discussed as
Georgia elections officials appear to be
on the cusp of certifying Republican
Brian Kemp as the winner of a bitterly
fought campaign that's been marred by
charges of electoral malfeasance Oh
who's making those charges of electoral
malfeasance Democrats and yet we keep
hearing that it's Republicans like
president Trump undermining electoral
integrity oh those evil Republicans
pointing out election irregularities
that actually exist in Florida but when
Democrats complain about election
regularities that actually don't exist
in Georgia then it's totally fine we're
not hearing anything about it now I do
have to give some credit to Jake Tapper
here so Jake Tapper you know I there I
get a lot of letters saying why are you
so easy on Jake Tapper the reason that I
am easy on Jake Tapper is because I
think I'm trying to be objective about
Jake Tapper when he does stuff I don't
like I note it but when he does stuff
that's right he deserves praise
here was Jake Tapper yesterday on CNN
doing what he's supposed to do going
after Hillary Clinton and sherrod Brown
for implying that the Georgia State
Governor race was rigged and you know
good for Jake Tapper well take a listen
Republicans are not actually the only
ones trashing the other party and sowing
doubts about the integrity of the
process take a look at what it's being
said about the Georgia governor's race
which is also not over
Democrat Stacey Abrams still trails
Republican Brian Kemp the race has not
been called take a listen to what some
Democrats have said if Stacey Abrams
doesn't win in Georgia they stole it
it's clear it's clear if she'd had a
fair election she already would have won
is that really any different from what
the Matt Gaetz is and Donald Trump's of
the world are doing okay and this is
exactly right okay this is exactly right
the only difference is that Trump has
more evidence of Florida election
malfeasance than Stacey Abrams does
that's not stopping the Democrats from
calling for new elections is why I was
always a lie when they were claiming you
know Trump is gonna protest the election
it'll ruin the legitimacy we're now two
years into Democrats claiming that the
entire election was swung by Vladimir
Putin and Julian Assange spare me all of
your hysterics about Republicans
violating electoral integrity
hey in just a second I want to talk a
little bit more about what's gonna
happen in Georgia plus I need to get to
the big ruling today on Jim Acosta who
loves him some Jim Acosta but first
let's talk about your internet security
and privacy okay as a public figure I'm
constantly worried about being hacked or
spied on because there are bad people
out there I know they're bad people out
there and I don't want my emails
compromised or my credit card stolen or
my credit card number taken yet that
happens to hundreds of millions of
people every year so how can you protect
yourself well the company I trust to
defend my online security and privacy is
expressed VPN expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your connection by encrypting
a hundred percent of your network data
and hiding your IP address that means
nobody can record or access your online
activity download the expressvpn app on
your computer or smartphone and then use
the internet just as you normally would
you click one button in the expressvpn
app and voila you are now protected
expressvpn is consistently rated the
world's number one VPN service for
Internet users there's a reason for that
it's super easy to use and it protects
you the nice folks at expressvpn have
extended special pricing less than seven
bucks per month to all my fans right now
so visit expressvpn comm slash Ben to
claim your discount again that's
expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn more
no reason to leave yourself exposed to
folks who want to take all your
information expressvpn comm slash Ben
again that's expressvpn comm slash Ben
go claim your discount right now so
Allegra Lawrence Hardy is stacey abrams
campaign chairwoman she's overseeing a
team of almost three dozen lawyers who
in the coming days
draft the petition along with a ream of
affidavits from voters and would-be
voters who say they were disenfranchised
you know it's easy to do coming up with
affidavits from people who say they were
disenfranchised after they know that a
candidate lost kind of easy to do that
lots of people gonna say you know what I
was really meaning to vote but then the
machines all broke down kind of voter
fraud sorta okay not great
kay Abrams would then decide whether to
go to court under a provision of florida
of georgia election law that allows
losing candidates to challenge results
based on misconduct fraud or
regularities sufficient to change or
place in doubt the results the legal
team is considering all the options the
state challenge would be the most
drastic some democrat legal observers
note that she would actually have to
pass a pretty high bar in order for her
to depend on that statute
Kemp's campaign has already shifted into
transition mode and they are right to do
so unofficial returns show Kemp with
about fifty point two percent of more
than three point nine million votes
which puts him about eighteen thousand
votes above the threshold required to
win by a majority and he's some fifty
three thousand votes ahead of Stacey
Abrams there is no way she can make that
up in any sort of legitimate way but
Democrats are not shy about doing this
in an illegitimate way apparently so
again it's if we're gonna talk about
lack of faith in public institutions
Democrats have been heavily involved in
this lack of faith in public
institutions we have now heard them rail
against the electoral college which
apparently is illegitimate because
Hillary Clinton lost we have heard them
rail against the Senate itself because
the Senate is somehow illegitimate
because Democrats don't run it we've
heard them rail against the Supreme
Court and talking about packing the
Supreme Court because they don't control
the Supreme Court in the same way that
they once did we have heard them rail
about pretty much every aspect of the
American electoral system over the last
two years and then meanwhile complain
that President Trump is undermining the
integrity of America's constitutional
system well case one in their exhibit is
of course his treatment of the press and
the latest evidence that they have is a
judge who just sided against the White
House with regard to Jim Acosta so here
is the latest on case acosta very very
important stuff so as you will recall
Jim Acosta got into a spat with
President Trump the day after the
midterm elections in which he basically
got up and started railing against
President Trump basically doing an op-ed
that Trump was supposed to rebut Trump
didn't water about it at a certain point
Whitehouse internal Andover grab the
microphone from Acosta Acosta sort of
pulled away and then he continued to
talk and then finally Trump walked away
from the microphone which is what he
probably should have done before that
and then Acosta hands it over the
microphone and as I said at the time if
you want to revoke Jim Acosta's press
pass on the basis that he was
essentially violating the rules of the
press corps then I think that's
perfectly appropriate Jim Acosta is a
grandstander Jim Acosta loves him some
Jim Acosta he's a terrible reporter I
know a lot of people who work at CNN
virtually all of them think Jim Acosta
is a schmuck par excellence that the guy
is just a self-aggrandizing idiot who
spends all of his time not reporting but
patting himself on the back and then
quaffing his hair they nobody even at
CNN really likes Jim Acosta very much
but because Trump then revoked his press
pass and claimed in the process that he
had put his hands on an intern which is
controversial to say the least it looks
more to me like there's an incidental
contact when she goes for the microphone
in any case the Acosta team basically
claimed in CNN claims and Fox News
backed them in their in their lawsuit
claim that this was viewpoint
discrimination that the real reason that
Jim Acosta had had his press pass
revoked was because Jim Acosta had been
engaging in anti Trump activities by by
yelling at the president's or another
now as I said I thought that case was
kind of weak from Jim Acosta simply
because there are a bunch of other
members of the press corps who are
similarly anti Trump and their press
pass has not been revoked April Ryan
comes to mind who's been extraordinarily
anti Trump throughout but there's a
ruling today it came down from a federal
judge Timothy Keller
Akeley who was a trump appointee and he
was appointed by 94 to to vote I federal
judge Kelley sided with CNN on Friday
morning he ordered the White House to
reinstate Jim Acosta's press pass
immediately the ruling was an initial
victory for CNN and its lawsuit against
President Trump in several top aides the
suit alleges CNN and Acosta's 1st and
5th Amendment rights were being violated
by suspension of his Press Pass here was
Jim Acosta's response and I want to get
into the actual legalities of this
ruling hi everybody thanks for coming I
just want to say something very briefly
and that is I want to thank all of my
colleagues in the press who supported us
this week
and I want to thank the judge for the
decision he made today and let's go back
to work thank you
what oh my goodness such journalism a
such heroism
well look at that man I mean that man
he's basically I mean it's like Gideon's
trumpet right here I mean this guy is
just defending First Amendment rights
the guy just has an incredible sense of
the Constitution and family you have a
free press that's what's going on here
it's not just an ego played by Jim
Acosta this entire thing again where
he's gonna bust into that press room and
it's gonna be like that scene from
anchorman where all the press corps
fighting each other was with pitchforks
and he's throwing torches at Sarah
Huckabee Sanders or anything he is just
he is the classiest of us he really is
okay so what exactly did the judge rule
well what the press are saying that the
judge ruled is not actually what the
judge ruled so the the implication from
CNN is this is a vindication of Jim
Acosta's First Amendment rights well
actually the First Amendment issue was
not actually touched by the judge
timothy kelly in this case he granted a
temporary restraining order which is not
a final actual it's not actually a final
resolution of the issue a government
lawyer James Burnham he argued in a
hearing before Kelly on Wednesday the
president was within his rights to ban
any reporter from the White House at any
time just as he excludes reporters from
interviews in the Oval Office he said a
cost I could report on the president
just as effectively by watching the
President on TV or by calling sources
within the White House
Burnham also explained the Trump's
rationale for the castas ban with his
rudeness at last week's press conference
that drew a rebuttal from CNN's lawyer
who described the ban on the reporter as
arbitrary capricious and unprecedented
well there are two issues at play here
issue number one was is it viewpoint
discrimination to ban Jim Acosta right
that is that is question number one and
question number two was was this a
violation of due process meaning does
there has to be some process some
explanation of the rule that was
violated in order to remove Jim Acosta's
Press Pass the judge in this particular
case said the due process was violated
but he did not actually he did not
actually get to the First Amendment
issue
he said the White House's
decision-making was so shrouded in
mystery that the government could not
tell me who made the decision and the
White House's later written arguments
for banning Acosta were belated and
weren't sufficient to satisfy due
process said Kelly so there are people
saying today the White House doesn't
need to have a due process for removing
his Press Pass I think that that's
misstated once you give somebody a press
pass there has to be some sort of
process for removing it that has to be
fulfilled the cancerous B we're pulling
this guy's press pass for no reason
because we feel like it that's not
something that really fulfills sort of
constitutional muster I sort of agree
with the ruling I even agree with the
idea that this could have been construed
as I say as a viewpoint discrimination
issue but that is not a case that the
court actually reached because a
temporary restraining order the judge
didn't reach the First Amendment
question but CNN is saying a major
precedent was set for the future of a
Free Press
it was not okay no major precedent was
set and then let me explain that in just
one second so no major precedent was set
here because in order for a precedent to
have been set here there would have had
to be been a ruling saying that you
can't ban anyone from the White House
press corps for any reason having to do
with any sort of behavior right that
would have been a major precedent but
that's not what it said what they said
is we need to know how you came to this
decision since we don't know how you
came to this decision it looks arbitrary
and capricious and therefore a violation
of due process okay again I don't think
it's the world's strongest ruling I
don't think is the world's weakest
ruling but I don't think that again it's
it's completely unjustified I think that
a stronger rule and listen the reason
that I'm defending the ruling a little
bit here is because there will be a
point at some point in the future
whether it is in four years or whether
it's in eight years or whether it is in
12 years when a Democrat is in the White
House again and that Democrat will be
using the precedent set here to ban
reporters from the right from the White
House without due process somebody gets
up and asks Kamala Harris a question god
forbid the president and she says I
don't like that guy get him out and so
they banned him now I don't like that
precedent so would I rather have Jim
Acosta making an ass of himself in the
press room then have there be a
precedent that the White House can ban
whoever it pleases yeah I would yeah I
really would especially because it
doesn't hurt President Trump to have Jim
Acosta in there in fact it probably
helps him every time Jim Acosta makes a
fool of himself president Trump will do
better the press secretary put out a
statement today the court made clear
there is no absolute First Amendment
right to access the White House which no
one had really claimed there was an
absolute First Amendment right the
question is whether once you're granted
a press pass it can be rejected on an
arbitrary and capricious basis in
response to the court will temporarily
reinstate the reporters hard pass we'll
also further develop rules and processes
to ensure fair and orderly press
conferences in the future there must be
decorum at the White House okay so
that's about the
right outcome and undoubtedly there'll
be an opportunity to ban Jim Acosta
again because he's not going to abide by
any rules of decency in any of this so
is this a huge deal no it's not will the
press treat it as a huge deal
sure is it good that the White House
actually has to show some precedent some
certain actual process here for banning
reporters I think in the long run it
probably is okay meanwhile demonstrating
once again the Democrats do not know how
to run major cities New York has been
hit by some snow and a left commuters
stranded for up to 12 hours my sister
lives in the general New York New Jersey
area and it was taking people six hours
to move a couple of miles thanks to some
snow which does go to city management's
and state management it really does
because it's not like they've never had
snow in New York before so I get snowed
in LA or something and then everybody's
oh my god it's snowing it's snowing in
New York which is something that has
happened in the past as in every single
year according to weather calm
conditions were improving for most in
the Northeast Friday after winter storm
Avery left at least 11 dead in accidents
blamed on the ice and snow and stranded
commuters for up to 12 hours knocking
out power to hundreds of thousands and
forcing some students to stay at school
overnight Thursday evenings commute
became an absolute nightmare for drivers
especially in parts of New York New
Jersey and Pennsylvania traffic SATs
still for hours on Turnpike's and
interstates and crawled at a snail's
pace when it could move New York drivers
reported being stranded for up to seven
hours so well done all local officials
obviously the government doing a
fantastic job over there the George
Washington Bridge was basically in total
lockdown because there was some snow the
Holland Tunnel and the Lincoln Tunnel
were both experiencing delays the GW was
actually closed a disabled semi-trailer
truck walked all westbound lanes with
the Gowanus Expressway at the Belt
Parkway split in Brooklyn about 4:30
p.m. Central Park received six inches of
snow by Thursday evening the Port
Authority bus terminal in Manhattan was
closed to anymore passengers about 5:30
p.m. because it was so overcrowded I
know I had heard from my sister who
lives in the area that there was a
wedding that was scheduled for last
night and legitimately six people showed
up to the wedding because of all of the
weather this does raise some broader
questions about whether the real threat
in terms of weather is additional heat
or weather
actually additional cold according to
CBS local despite the snow blitz of 2015
many baby boomers still insist that
overall we don't get the harsh bitter
cold and deep snowy winters like we did
in the good old days weather records
prove that just isn't the case and
despite the ongoing claims that snows
are becoming rare and heard him winter
sports this millennium has been a
blessing to snow lovers and winter
sports enthusiasts just as the Saffir
Simpson and Fujita scales were devised
to categorize hurricanes and tornadoes
the Northeast snowfall impact scale was
created by Paul Kosan of the National
Weather Service to rank high-impact
northeast storms the scale has five
categories and the highest the highest
category storm has been increasing
rapidly this is why you've seen a lot of
people when they talk about climate
change instead of talking about about
global warming per se they start talking
instead about climate radicalism
basically so maybe there's a new
paradigm right the earth may be actually
experiencing a major cooling occurrence
I mean we just don't know may arctic
temperatures and Arctic ice extent
varies in a predictable 60 to 70 year
cycle the greatest warming has been
happening the Arctic region that can
produce a weaker less stable jet stream
allowing frigid air to dive further
south to mix with the warmer oceans to
trigger more potential snow events it's
all cyclical this is according to Barry
Burbank over at Boston and CBS local so
we simply don't know the effect of all
of this but again this is up to local
governments to solve and obviously
they're not doing an appropriate job in
doing so okay meanwhile when there is a
there's a a an obvious attempt in the in
the Republican in the Republican caucus
to ignore the results of what is now
amounting to a blue wave in the house
overall what we've watched unrolling in
slow fashion since the 2018 election is
more and more democratic seats being
piled up Orange County which used to be
a Republican stronghold as late as 2016
all of the congressional districts in
Orange County save one went red in this
last election cycle every single
congressional district in Orange County
went blue some people are attributing
that to the influx of Latino immigrants
who are coming from you know areas south
of the border and the idea is that
because of President Reagan's amnesty
and changing demographics in Orange
County that's why you've seen all this
that doesn't explain why Texas has
stayed red
even though the demographics of Texas
have shifted pretty radically instead
you have to assume that blue turnout was
really high and suburban Republicans are
not very fond of President Trump and
this is a serious problem for President
Trump going forward it's an even more
serious problem if Republicans refuse to
acknowledge the issue here and I'm
seeing a little bit of that vice
president Pence said yesterday that he
didn't really see a blue wave in the
house this is just incorrect we made
history by expanding our majority in the
Senate we have we won some great
elections and governors offices around
the country and and we didn't really see
that blue wave in the House of
Representatives come are we not true
okay it's gonna be about 40 seats by the
time all of this is done the fact is
Republicans dramatically underperformed
in this election cycle that is
particularly true in suburbia what we
are watching is that suburban areas
across the country are voting very much
alike a suburban area in Oklahoma is now
voting like in a suburban area in
California rural areas in California are
voting like rural areas in Georgia and
urban areas in Georgia are voting like
urban areas in New York so basically we
now have a split in the country that is
not necessarily area driven it's mainly
driven by urban suburban and rural hit
problem is that suburban folks tend to
be a little bit more moderate suburban
folks tend to not just in terms of
policy but in terms of the attitude and
because they tend to be a little bit
more moderate in terms of attitude they
are off-put by a lot of the radical
rhetoric coming from President Trump the
statistics tend to show that a lot of
suburban Republicans actually voted for
Democrats in the last election cycle
which i think is unthinkable but that's
what happened in Arizona right Kristin
Sonoma is the new senator from Arizona
because 14 percent of registered
Republicans in the state votes voted for
a woman who said in 2003 that she didn't
mind if Americans joined the Taliban a
that is because Kristin sedima actually
ran a moderate campaign and Kristin
senemo said that she would negotiate on
the border wall she said that she would
not back Chuck Schumer for a Senate
majority leader although she now is
going to do exactly that she flipped on
that within 12 hours
in fact his suburban Republicans are
being alienated by the Republican Party
and doubling down on what brought us
here is not necessarily a recipe for
future victory you have to shift and
move as you as you learn more things and
right now the Republicans are not
shifting and moving now the good news is
Democrats aren't shifting or moving
either what they should be learning is
that moderation would actually be of
benefit here but instead it seems like
they are going to continue
shift radically to the left we'll talk
about that in just a second plus it will
get to a interesting study talking about
why young people aren't having as much
sex as they used to I have an answer for
you but first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wear comm for $9.99 a
month subscribe to daily wear comm get
the rest of my show live get the rest of
Andrew Klavan show live get the rest of
Michael Knowles's show live be part of
our mailbag which we are doing today
taking your questions also if you get
your subscription then you won't miss
Andrew kleavon's next chapter of another
Kingdom performed by the execrable
Michael Mills who's better actor than he
is a human today we'll be live-streaming
the first 15 minutes of episode 7 titled
the secret of horror mansion also known
as Andrew Cuomo's house head on over to
daily wire comm and subscribe to watch
the full episode and get early access to
upcoming episodes every single Monday we
have all sorts of goodies that are going
to be behind the paywall in very short
order you're not gonna want to miss them
go over and subscribe right now when you
get the annual subscription you get this
the very greatest in beverage vessels as
you see we have deactivated the cloaking
device on the beverage vessel and
because we are back in Los Angeles and
now we are in safe territory so others
can observe the beauties of this left is
tears hot recalled tumblr can be yours
for 99 dollars a year which is cheaper
than the monthly subscription I know
don't be deceived 99 dollars even though
it's more than $9.99 on a yearly basis
follow the math on the annual basis $99
is less than $9.99 a month I know it's
crazy go check it out right now the
annual subscription also subscribe over
to iTunes or at YouTube when you do you
get our Sundays special we have former
Canadian Prime Minister Stephen Harper
and we have a bunch of people who are
coming up we're gonna be just
spectacular as well are something
special very popular stuff so many
goodies go check it out subscribe leave
us a review over at iTunes it really
helps us
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so if Republicans refuse to change
course Democrats are also refusing to
change course and this is a mistake for
them if they would change course they
would actually have a serious shot at
winning a broad majority in 2020 but
Nancy Pelosi
says that she has overwhelming support
to be speaker this is one of the things
that's so fascinating about our politics
right now is that both parties seem like
they are radicalizing but the leadership
is the same which suggests that the base
is indeed in charge of the leadership so
Nancy Pelosi was the head of Congress in
2006 and then shoes boots in 2010 and
now she's back in 2018 right she's been
majority leader and minority leader
majority leader again in the in the
house for Republicans every time they
boot somebody it's just the next person
in line who gets the jobs the new House
Minority Leader is gonna be Kevin
McCarthy it was sort of next in line
after Paul Ryan it didn't turn out to be
it didn't turn out to be any of the
other candidates who are up for Jim
Jordan was the one from Ohio who is sort
of up for it he only won 43 votes so the
parties tend to maintain their
leadership which suggests that party
leadership is basically in the sway of
the base so if they're radicalizing it's
more about the base than it is about the
leadership in other words it's the
Democratic base driving Nancy Pelosi and
not necessarily the other way around
here's Nancy Pelosi announcing she has
overwhelming support to be Speaker I
have overwhelming support in my caucus
to be Speaker of the House and certainly
we had many many people in our caucus
who could serve in this capacity I
happen to think that at this point I'm
the best person for that okay so she's
gonna stick around and as I said
yesterday
Alexandra Ocasio cortes who's going to
be one of the kind of new leaders in the
house she is because she's turning out
to be a pretty clever politician in her
own right
part of that is helped by the fact that
Republicans are attacking her in the
dumbest possible way there's a tweet
yesterday that I mean got ratioed in
epic fashion for people who don't follow
Twitter a ratio is when more people
comment on your tweet than like your
tweet okay in this particular case this
tweet received something like 20,000
comments and about a hundred likes he
got just got destroyed in epic fashion
Eddie scary who works for the Washington
Examiner he tweeted out a picture of
Ocasio Cortes walking away in the hall
he said Hill staffers
me this pic of ocassi accord says they
took just now I'll tell you something
that jacket and coat don't look like a
girl who struggles I mean I'm not too
sure what you should be wearing exactly
like a barrel with suspenders way she's
wearing what looks like a fairly normal
skirt suit I'm not sure why she's
supposed to be dressed like a hobo or
something and I know a lot of people who
are lower middle-income who still dress
decently so that that of course is an
idiotic attack like just attack her
ideas her ideas are dumb enough you
don't to attack her wardrobe it's really
silly you know a few weeks ago it was
different when she was wearing like
legitimate thousand-dollar jackets while
posing on a stoop in the Bronx I mean
that's just kind of ridiculous but you
know for it to attack like the fact that
she's dressed okay while she's walking
through Congress is really silly
nonetheless Ocasio Cortez is proving
herself capable of posturing according
to Politico a fight broke out him in a
closed-door meeting of House Democrats
over climate change has a powerful
veteran lawmaker fought with
representative elect Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez and other members elect over the
creation of a special panel for climate
change New Jersey representative Frank
pallone was the incoming chairman of the
powerful Energy and Commerce Committee
slammed the creation of a new climate
panel he said that his committee and
other existing panels within the house
could take on the issue aggressively but
a bunch of a bunch of other progressive
incoming lawmakers fought back
they said they ran on the issue and they
needed to start a green new deal and
they want a new and they said that they
they want a new climate panel but then
she's smart enough to say that she never
actually fought with him so I never had
a direct interaction with him today and
by direct interaction I mean I didn't
share a conversation I did say hello and
he's very kind so Ocasio Cortez knows
where her bread is buttered with the
House leadership and she continues to
pander to that House leadership again
she's proven herself to be adept at this
so watch out Republicans because you
know you need to actually be you need to
be going after her policies not her
political acumen the only person who is
successfully going after her political
acumen sits behind this desk be when she
suggested that I can't call her after I
said maybe we should have a discussion
in any case another big story out today
the Atlantic has a new long piece about
why these should be boom times for sex
because the number of Americans who
morally disapprove of sex outside of
marriage is at an all-time low new cases
of HIV are an all-time low most women
can get birth control for free and the
morning-after pill without a
prescription and yet
yet American teenagers and young adults
are having less sex through a relief of
many parents educators and clergy
members who care about the health and
well-being of young people teens are
launching their sex lives later from
1991 to 2017 the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention's youth risk
behavior survey found the percentage of
high school students who'd had
intercourse dropped from 54% to 40% so
sex has gone from something most high
school students had experienced to
something that most haven't and that's
not because they're substituting other
forms of sex u.s. teen pregnancy has
plummeted to a third of its modern high
so why is all of this happening why is
all of this happening
well the general answer honestly is that
pornography has taken over okay this is
the real answers that people are staying
home people are not getting involved in
relationships they're figuring it that
if we have now disconnected sex from
relationships why bother even hanging
out with a person of the opposite sex
and the statistics bear this out without
getting too graphic no this is a serious
it's a serious issue because it does
lead to later relationships and it's
funny that the Atlantic is worried about
less sex as opposed to later
relationships but they really should be
worried about later relationships no I
won't explain that for just thinking so
let's talk about this it used to be that
sex and relationships were deeply
intertwined right in in my life
my sex life and my relationship with my
wife were United right I didn't have sex
until I was married to my wife which
used to be at least the traditional
standard of morality and that was good
because it led people to get married to
get married younger and led people to
have children younger and start becoming
responsible citizens younger and then
they were actually having a fair bit of
sex because it turns out that married
people on average do have more sex than
non married people and then the left
side you know what let's disconnect sex
from relationship sex doesn't have to be
about marriage doesn't have to be about
love it doesn't have to be about
commitment and so the sex rates went up
because in the immediate aftermath of
that social move everybody's like okay
let's get our rocks off let's do this
thing and then it turned out a couple of
things happen one a lot of women decided
that it actually isn't that fulfilling
to have random sex with strangers and
that they don't actually want just the
physical pleasure of sex they actually
want emotional connection with people
and to a bunch of young men decided okay
well
if sex is no longer supposed to be
connected with relationships and if I
can get pornography online from the time
that I am a kid then why would I bother
with all of this relationship stuff it
seems like kind of a hassle sex and
relationships have to be interconnected
and that was a good deal it was a good
deal for men things have made them more
responsible and they got more sex out of
it and it was a good deal for women
because women got relationships and
commitment out of it and they also got
more sex out of it once you disconnected
sex and relationships there's a natural
inclination by men toward promiscuity
but women don't necessarily want to
engage in that same promiscuity and if
men can simply fantasize next to their
computer every day then it turns out the
rates of actual interaction between
human beings is going to go down in
other words social liberalism has not
led to happiness social liberalism has
has led to deep unhappiness and deep
loneliness and you can see this right
there's a great quote from this piece
from a from a particular scholar saying
saying basically we hook up because we
have no social skills we have no social
skills because because we hook up this
is exactly right and people don't know
how to get along with other people
because the expectation is sex rather
than relationships and I notice this in
sitcoms maybe 20 years ago where there's
this weird vibe but there's this weird
reversal of the polarity when it came to
relationships and sex so if you watch
old movies the idea was that the
culmination of the movie would be
someone says I love you
and then you slowly pan to the curtains
right that was always how it worked in
the old movies when you couldn't show
sex on the screen somebody would say I
love you hands of the curtains now it's
you show the full sex scene and then the
next morning someone awkwardly says I
love you and then somebody gets offended
and leaves
well that reversal has not been good for
men or women because for particularly
for women sex is deeply connected with
commitment and emotional intimacy and
for men if you disconnect those things
then it's just a question of how often
they can get their rocks off and it
turns out it's a lot easier to get your
rocks off sitting in your basement
watching watching porn on your computer
it's emptying people's lives it's
destroying people's lives and to fail to
note this is to is to fail to understand
why it is that people are unhappy so the
Atlantic
tributing that's who lack of sex it's
not lack of sex that's making people
unhappy it's unhappiness that's leading
to lack of sex right it's it's it's lack
of relationships and emotional intimacy
in connection with other people that is
leading to lack of sex because it turns
out that sex without all of those things
is just another biological function this
is like saying people are eating less
than their you than they used to why is
that so terrible well I mean it's not
inherently terrible is the answer people
having sex less than they used to is not
inherently terrible what is inherently
terrible is people being depressed
people being upset people being lonely
we are in a lonely loneliness epidemic
we have lost social connection with
other human beings
because social connection requires
commitment it requires shared values
it requires the idea that you're going
to get together with people who you have
in obligation to beyond merely your own
pleasure
and since we've thrown all of that out
the window then why connect with other
people at all why not simply head your
basement and that's exactly what people
have been doing you want to restore
happiness you want to restore healthy
sex lives to people restore emotional
intimacy restore connection restore
commitment restore all of these things
and you'll make people happy and yes the
rates of sex will go back up as a
byproduct and all of that will be good
because then sex will be had within a
healthy context and not an unhealthy
context okay time for some mail bags so
let's do a few questions from the
mailbag John says hi Ben what
circumstances or events do you think
would be severe enough to warrant an
execution of the Second Amendment and
it's true intention as a revolt against
government tyranny well I know that this
is its purpose I've never thought of
what would trigger its use in this form
any thoughts are appreciated okay well I
think that for example if the government
came to confiscate all weapons that
would be a good time to stand up on your
hind legs and say we are not going to
allow this to happen if the government
were to revoke full-on religious freedom
I think that if you have no other place
to run now you try to avoid violence at
first at first blush always but if it
turns out there's like a national policy
for example then you do have to stand up
and say no I mean if somebody tried to
take away my kid because I was teaching
my kid my religious precept then I would
stand up with my gun and I would say no
Elliott says dear Ben with progressives
like Alexandra Ocasio occasional cortex
okay already causing trouble for House
Democrats do you think that the
radically progressive left is going to
unite with more traditional Democrats
again
the right in 2020 or whether it will
they succumb to infighting well I think
Trump is a unifying factor what you
could see and this is what really hurt
Hillary Clinton in 2016 is that Hillary
Clinton had a person running from her
left who basically split the base a lot
of those Sanders voters did not show up
for Hillary Clinton I think that is
unlikely to happen this time I think
it's more likely that the base captures
the nomination then that some approved
candidate from the top is selected by
the Democrats what that means that they
may not run somebody so moderate but
they will run somebody who's more
approved by the base they got rid of the
super-delegates I think the possibility
of a United Democratic Party that is
more radical is better in 2020 than the
possibility of a moderate Democratic
Party that is split drew says hey Ben I
know that you are against euthanasia
however I've run into a bit of a hurdle
when I take it to the logical conclusion
in certain cases when someone is near
death often even a small pain reliever
will assist in the death of a patient do
you believe it would be immoral for a
doctor to give a patient who's in a lot
of pain and close to death a small pain
reliever knowing that it could kill the
patient thanks for everything
drew no I I don't think that that's
immoral I think that giving pain
relievers to people who are you know
right on the precipice of death in order
to relieve pain is one thing I think
deliberately killing the patient is
another thing there there is such a
thing as sort of a dual by-product when
you're attempting to alleviate pain and
a possible risk of that is death that's
not the same thing as I'm going to I'm
going to you know shoot chloroform into
your veins or something Meghan's has
been I've noticed that people use the
terms Republican democracy
interchangeably isn't there a big
difference between the two and why would
it be okay for us to use both when
describing our country well we are a
democratic republic in and the reason
that we shouldn't really use them
interchangeably is because direct
democracy would mean that we all vote on
every issue Republic means that we have
representatives who represent us and
that there are checks and balances in
the system direct democracies tend to
perish pretty quickly the founders in
the Federalist Papers as we've talked
about nearly every week are very much
against the idea of direct democracy
they like the idea of checks and
balances and you're right we should not
be conflating Republican democracy but
democracy can encompass Republic in the
sense that we are a system wherein the
votes of people are counted and policy
is based on the votes of those people
via our elected representatives so I
would say that every Republic is it is a
democracy but not every democracy as a
republic and
that's fair Kimberly says hey Ben do you
think President Nixon was as bad as
people make him out to be or is just
overblown outraged well I think that he
was a worse president than a lot of
Republicans think he was but I'd know I
mean I think the idea that that
Watergate was some sort of was some sort
of horrific violation of American
American electoral norms is just silly I
mean there's there's good information
that the Lyndon Johnson campaign was
bugging Barry Goldwater's headquarters
in 1964 so was it bad yes it was bad was
it the worst thing that ever happened in
the history of the American Republic no
wasn't anything remotely like that no
what was worse was the cover-up and
again you know I disagreed Nixon a lot
on policy the man implemented price and
wage controls and I'm still quite split
over whether it was worth while opening
China in the first place but was Nixon
as you know the the forerunner of
tyrannical evil in the United States no
that's that's silliness Nicholas has my
wife noted that all comedians nowadays
want to be political while you being
political want to be a comedian any new
impressions who are working on that we
can look forward to
we both love your show and appreciate
your sometimes Trump approach keep it up
well you know I don't actually want to
be a comedian because being a comedian
means that your job is to be funny all
the time I like what I do because it
means that when I meet somebody on the
street their first thing isn't tell me a
joke make me laugh
funny man right there's less of an
obligation for me to be funny the humor
in my show sort of just comes out
naturally and I think that this is the
problem for a lot of comedians who want
to be political once you get political
you are now in my sphere and that means
that you have to make good arguments
means you have to back those arguments
with evidence if you're a Jimmy Kimmel
then you can't just pretend to be a
comedian every time it suits you and
then be a political commentator at other
times I don't pretend to be a comedian
meaning I'm not gonna go up against
Jimmy Kimmel in a funny contest you
would beat me every time and that's true
for most comedians yeah I'm not gonna
try stand-up any time my friend Dave
Rubin has suggested I go try stand-up no
not particularly interested but I do
think that people should basically stick
to their own lines and there is such a
thing as a funny political commentator
as far as as far as new impressions I
have to find somebody whose voice and
mannerisms are kind of prominent enough
that I can do them my impressions are
quite broad as you may have noticed
except for Obama my Obama's quite good
lisa has dear Ben I was watching CBS
Evening News the other night and they
spoke about how Congress has warned that
the u.s. is unprepared
against rising China and Russian
military expansion even though we spend
more money than both combined do you
believe these fears are warranted do you
think boosting our military spending is
the best option to curb them well we
have been raising our military spending
but we need to be modernizing our
military in a variety of ways Barack
Obama slashed our military dramatically
it's going to take us a while to rebuild
all of that and it's not that we're
unprepared for Russia I mean we could
take out Russia individually we could
take out China individually the question
is can we fight two wars at once the
Obama administration said it didn't want
to the Obama administration basically
said we no longer need to be an army
prepared to fight two wars and on two
fronts at once I think that is
completely wrong headed Katz has been
other than Trump toning down his style
and rhetoric what are steps the
Republican Party can take to win back
the suburban women vote well you know I
think that obviously president Trump is
the chief factor in driving away the
suburban woman vote but I think that
talking about safety and security
talking to seed about security to to
suburban women is a good pitch right
it's how Rudy Giuliani became mayor in
New York suburban women these are the
security moms from 2004 they are still
deeply concerned about safety security
crimer and these are issues without
being catastrophic about it these are
issues where Democrats are incredibly
soft and Republicans simply are not and
I think could that be a good way of
reaching out to suburban women I think
also that suburban women want to know
that their children are going to be
protected from the predations of the
radical social left and so reminding the
these and so reminding mom's right
soccer moms that they should have
autonomy in their own homes and that
they will have support from their local
community to do so but I think that's
worthwhile but again I think the policy
is largely secondary to voters because
voters swing wildly on policy voters are
sometimes in favor one thing sometimes
they're in favor of another personality
does matter a lot in presidential
elections okay here's the final question
let's see did you do Nate since you
mentioned this week that there isn't or
at least you don't see evidence of a
voter fraud on the left I asked with
genuine curiosity does the case with
Brenda Snipes not count as full-fledged
evidence in that regard well as I said
earlier on the show
I'm coming closer to suggesting that
voter fraud is a serious possibility in
Florida when Democrats are sending out
forums that are illegally marked in
order to drive people to file forms on
the off chance that a judge decides to
rewrite election law so yeah
I'm a lot more skeptical that there's no
such thing as quote-unquote election
fraud after watching all of that okay
time for a thing that I like and then
we'll do a thing I hate and then we'll
take a weekend so things that I like and
so I was watching the movie tag on the
plane I it's not a great movie
by any stretch of the imagination it's
based on a story in the Wall Street
Journal a few years back about this
group of friends who had basically been
playing tag for 30 years and they spent
a month every year playing tag like
trying to hide in different places to
try and tag each other and the premise
in the movies that there's one guy who
has never been tagged and so all of his
friends are trying to sort of ambush him
and then tag him i the movie is I won't
say it's a spectacularly funny movie
it's not there are a couple of sequences
though that are really quite funny
basically everything with Jeremy Runner
is really funny Jeremy Renner is one of
my favorite actors and and here's a
little bit of preview you may kiss the
bride
[Applause]
[Music]
please tell me what's going on here our
group of friends has been playing the
same game of tag for 30 years
what for the entire month of May every
year we play tag you never know when
someone's gonna pop up congratulations
buddy you're in doing great and our
buddy Jerry he's the best that ever
played and how he wants to retire never
been tagged just saying it was it
touched it sear we appear
supernatural watches I don't know how to
do that I don't wear watch time is a
construct the parts of movies that are
really playing basically every sequence
where Jeremy Renner is trying to avoid
capture by these guys is really funny
and you know you'll get a few laughs out
of it
Iowa Fisher is is basic she plays
basically the same part in every movie
so she's the same person that she was in
wedding crashers except now she's
married to Andy from the office but the
movie is is kind of fun so if you're if
you're looking for just a throwaway
movie that's that you get a kick out of
this one goes on the list okay time for
a thing that I hate so first off William
Goldman passed away today which is too
bad he 87 years old he wrote Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid all the
President's Men and misery he also was
involved he denied this but he was
definitely involved in writing Good Will
Hunting which Matt Damon Ben Affleck got
all the credit for he has he wrote a
couple of great memoirs about Hollywood
and what will recommend them
specifically next week he also did the
Princess Bride which is everybody's
favorite movie from the 1980s so you
know William Goldman again one of the
Great's critten and really a good
analyst of his own screenwriting so that
is too bad he called himself a novelist
to write screenplays but his screenplays
are better than his novels and so you
could easily do it next week I think
we'll recommend a bunch of William
Goldman script so that you can get into
sort of the William Goldman over but
it's it's over but he's um his stuff is
is well worth watching and we bid a fond
farewell to William Goldman Goldman okay
and in other news that noise made
there's a story from the New York Times
about how Facebook has quote-unquote
fought through crisis and it talked
about how evil Facebook is all of this
is a precursor to the Democrats trying
to pressure Facebook into mirroring
Democratic propaganda I mean this is
this is really what all of this is about
and you can spot it in the New York
Times piece there's nothing in the piece
that suggests that the that Facebook
really did anything wrong during 2015
2016 2017 and yet the piece is all about
how they weren't receptive enough to
Democratic complaints and therefore
they're evil so for example the Facebook
decided not to censor President Trump in
2015 when he was making comments about
Muslims and Mexicans because they said
that this is basically a free speech
issue and the New York Times says this
is just terrible it's just terrible so
for example here's the New York Times
they say
Donald Trump ran for president he
described Muslim immigrants and refugees
as a danger to America in December 2015
posted a statement on Facebook calling
for a total and complete shutdown on
Muslims entering the United States mr.
Zuckerberg was appalled
he asked Sheryl Sandberg and other
executives if mr. Trump had violated
Facebook's Terms of Service but some at
Facebook's of Summit Facebook viewed mr.
Trump's 2015 attack on Muslims as an
opportunity to finally take a stand
against the hate speech coursing through
its platform but miss Sandberg who is
edging back to work after the death of
her husband several months earlier
delegated the matter to a to one of her
one of her kind of underlings and Monica
Picard a former prosecutor whom she had
appointed and then they decided that
that mr. Trump's account should not be
actually violated Joel Kaplan who works
with Facebook as sort of a policy
adviser he said it could stoke a
conservative backlash she said don't
poke the bear and he was of course right
but the New York Times says that was
wrong that Facebook publisher was shut
down Trump who was then running for
president yeah right because that that
wouldn't be alienated every every person
in political America men
the New York Times suggests that the
that Facebook treated Russia as a
non-problem that they that they sort of
made light of the Russian intervention
first of all again the evidence that
Russia actually swung the election via
Facebook is ridiculous I remember we
reviewed this at the time when the
Senate committee put out the Senate
Intelligence Committee put out all the
evidence that Russia had had acted with
malice on Facebook and they were putting
up post that had like 115 shares come on
come on okay combined total of Russian
propaganda that had an impact on the
election is probably less than the
amount of impact that my facebook
account has on people in maybe a week
it's just ridiculous and and here's what
but here's how the New York Times
reported here's how their Times reports
it miss Sandberg and mr. Zuckerberg
decided to accede to decide to create a
group called Project P for propaganda to
study false Newt news on the site
according to people involved in the
discussions by January 2017 the group
knew that the original team had only
scratched the surface of Russian
activity on Facebook and pressured to
issue a public paper about the findings
but mr. Kaplan and other Facebook
executives objected Washington was
already reeling from an official finding
by American intelligence agencies that
Putin had personally ordered an
influencer campaign aimed
helping elect mr. Trump at Facebook
implicated Russia further mr. Kaplan
said Republicans would accuse the
company of siding with Democrats and a
Facebook pulled down Russians fake pages
regular Facebook users might also react
with outrage at having been deceived his
own mother-in-law mr. Caplan said had
followed a Facebook page created by
Russian trolls Ms Sandberg sided with
mr. Caplan and did not participate in
the conversations about the public paper
when it was published in April the word
Russian never appeared as it really
shouldn't have because the fact is that
Russia's impact on the election via
Facebook was incredibly minimal
incredibly minimal if at all but this
entire piece is designed to be about how
Facebook somehow favors Republicans or
is too nice to Republicans which is an
insane insane contention yeah I know
because we view the Facebook metrics
every day though when Facebook decided
to change its metrics like a year ago
that every conservative website took a
20 to 30 percent hit in the amount of
traffic it was receiving from Facebook
while a lot of left sites were basically
left alone but but this is all setting
up precedent for Democrats to try and
regulate facebook or threatened Facebook
with regulation in advance of the 2020
election so keep your eye on the ball
the Democrats are going to try to
crackdown on Facebook and shift the
entire social media platform in order to
take advantage of 2020 okay well we will
be back here next week with much much
more and we'll see you they have a great
weekend we'll see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018